well let's talk let's talk about the
polling data and how it's changing so
you know uh margery you're just
mentioning
it's not about science it's about
polling right now we're seeing you know
new york illinois you mentioned new
jersey they're starting to pull back on
their mandates we have this story from
timcast.com president biden's approval
rating falls below 40 percent according
to new poll the rate marks an all-time
average low for biden at 30 was it 39.8
in the real clear politics average that
is i believe like two two or three
points lower than where donald trump was
at the same time in his presidency
i think it's fair to say the democrats
have gotten the message when you look at
civics data
it's a website the civic spell of the
queue
you can see that on economics on covid
on
the direction of government independent
voters and republicans are very much in
alignment republicans absolutely think
the economy is trash
independent voters think the economy is
very very bad democrat voters think the
economy is good somehow i don't know why
they must be watching too much cnn yes
but that tracks true for almost every
issue wow black lives matter support uh
the covid response democrats think joe
biden did a great job independent voters
republicans are kind of like well
republicans are like it's miserable
independent voters are like it's pretty
bad so so you know it's it's weird
that we have democrats the voter base
believing something that most americans
or at least independent voters
republicans don't i think obviously it's
media
but i think the media narrative is
breaking that's why democrats are going
down in the polls so it's not even just
the polls it's that they've lost control
of the narrative which results in the
polls tanking which results in them
saying whatever they got to say to try
and win especially this year
i totally agree well you can't lie to
people over and over when they see
something different in their everyday
life when they're going to the gas pump
and gas is up to almost four dollars a
gallon when they're going to the grocery
store and the store shelves are empty
and and food prices have gone up and
then when they're taking their kids to
school and their children are healthy
and no one their children are just fine
after two years of covered 19 but yet
they're still being forced to wear masks
and then there's children you know
suffering like with speech therapy and
different type of you know special needs
kids these masks are terrible for them
and and so yeah it's it is a real issue
and you can't lie to people over and
over again on the news and when they see
something different in their everyday
life stacey abrams
melissa slotkin
you know stacey abram's sitting out with
all these kids wearing masks and she's
not doing it yeah i mean they're
basically telling you they don't care
they don't care let me say something
about stacey abrams because she's
running for governor in my state that
picture was infuriating to me i'm a mom
i've got three kids now my kids are
older but stacey abrams she is in the
height one of the highest risk factors
for coven 19 she's obese she is she's
obese i'm not trying to say anything
terrible about anyone but that is the
state of her health she's sitting on the
floor without a mask in front of all
these children who who are not at high
risk of covid19 that those are the facts
that's on the cdc that is the data that
science has not changed
she sits there without a mask i mean it
was infuriating to me there's no way
parents in georgia to want that woman to
be the governor of our state when that's
how she views children that she is
better than them and that they have to
sit there with a mask on while she gets
to take hers off why did she do it did
you guys know what was the purpose of
that photo it was really really badly
right for her it's not the first time
we've seen a democrat who advocates for
masks not wear one
a picture recently of obama we saw nancy
pelosi getting her hair done we saw
whitmer the same thing i think they're
just liars
they're they're lying about how they
really feel about masks and if they want
they if they don't do you see that video
of rashida tolede saying she's she's on
camera saying something like i only wear
this when the republicans are around or
they're filming me or something it's
it's the weirdest we can talk about
masks i'm gonna let thomas start
in the house of representatives there's
a rule that you have to wear a mask but
guess what it only applies when you're
in front of cameras huh what yes no yes
yes either the only place they enforce
the rule is in a committee where there
are cameras or on the floor of the house
not in the hallways and when you go in
the hallways oh wow you'll see democrats
take their masks off it's been that way
for over a year the whole yeah it's been
there ever since i it's been that way
the whole time for me only if there's
cameras sure now is that the whole is
but i don't wear mine is that codified
in the rules like it says in the
presence of cameras or no it doesn't say
in the presence of cameras functionally
they just don't enforce it unless
cameras are around they they
functionally do not enforce it anywhere
but on the floor or
in a committee where they're incredible
where i have over 100 000 in mask fines
and
my good friend thomas massey and i have
something fun going on i'm going to let
you tell so uh one day pelosi goes out
the the media says when are you going to
lift the masks fines or the masks rule
in the house because remember there was
a period of time where if you'd been
vaccinated you could take your mask off
right and most of congress had been
vaccinated so they asked pelosi and she
said until every member of congress is
vaccinated everybody's going to wear a
mask and i realized okay the mask rule
is now morphing into a vaccine rule
and so i organized i don't want to say i
led but i organized 10 members of
congress and marjorie was among them to
go to the floor of the house and
notoriously and openly violate this mask
rule
in front of the c-span cameras and we
were promptly fined for our
transgressions and if she had just sent
the bill to georgia for marjorie's case
or to kentucky in my case
she would have been fine we would have
thrown them in the trash and she
wouldn't have got her money
but what she did is she reduced our
salaries that's right whoa takes it off
on the front end how does she do that
well she violates the constitution to do
it because the constitution says that
the salaries are set by law and drawn
from the treasury to be set by law a law
has to pass the senate and be signed by
the president the 27th amendment to the
constitution the very last one to be
ratified ratified in 1992 but suggested
during the bill of rights says that
congressional salaries can't vary
without an intervening election
now why did they do that a lot of people
think it was so we wouldn't give
ourselves a raise that could be partly
true but in reality if you go back and
look at the debates they decided if
anybody could get control of a person's
sustenance of their salary they could
bend their will pretty easily and so
they made sure that you couldn't vary it
until there was an election so rich
yeah then but even that i mean
marjorie's got a hundred thousand
dollars of fines oh the next thing they
did because they figured out they can't
stop me from refusing to wear a bass
because they figured out i truly will
not stop doing it no matter how much
they find me and we are going to have a
very successful lawsuit i'm thrilled
about it um he explained it perfectly so
they sent a letter uh a letter was sent
to sergeant-at-arms saying that they
should put anyone without a mask up and
up into the coveted box and and no one
really no the public doesn't know about
the coveted box because it's not in view
of the c-span cameras the coveted box
nancy pelosi had it built uh right
before this the vote for speaker of the
house in january of 2021
it is a plexi glass box up in the corner
of the house chamber now the plexiglas
doesn't go all the way to the ceiling
and it's supposed to be the the original
design was for any house member uh to go
there if they were sick or having
symptoms of covid19 it wasn't for well
people uh unvaccinated people or people
without mask it was only for sick people
but then catherine clark who who called
representative catholic representative
catherine clark sent a letter to the
sergeant-at-arms because they're so
offended um at me or any or thomas or
anyone not wearing a mask and they want
to put us up in the in the coveted box
in the penalty box yes sounds like i
check you up into the penalty box this
is
beyond
i i when i think about how bad congress
is you know the first time you came
marjorie explained how they don't even
really vote on the bills they just like
i nay and then just like don it sounds
like congress isn't a real thing it's
like it's like a theater to make
americans think there's something
actually being done about our problems
speaking of theater do you remember the
title of this person who wants us in the
box now yes oh yes what was her title
assistant speaker assistant speaker of
the house we think that her real title
is assistant to the speaker right and
then she just marked out that's the
question that's a joke from the office
yeah
yes
that's right
i think it's funny that we're all
sitting here laughing and it sounds like
the institution is just completely in
decay and falling oh it gets worse we
can tell you more well i i was the guy
that everybody hated by the way i was
the most hated person in washington dc
now i'm just the most hated man now that
marjorie is there but before marjorie
got there in 2020 march 27th 2020 tenth
day of flattening the curve congress
decided to spend two trillion dollars
with nobody there and taking no vote
this is my favorite story thomas massey
story one of my favorites i got in the
car and drove to washington dc and
objected and i said the constitution
requires a quorum to be here in order to
pass this bill and they hated me nancy
pelosi called me a dangerous nuisance
tell him what a quorum is a quorum would
be at least half of congress needs to
show up to pass which is how many people
218. how many people how many were there
well they were going to do it with one
in the speaker's chair and one on the
floor they were going to do it with two
people that's like it so remember i was
telling you they they'll pass bills with
only a couple people in there saying yes
or no that is exactly what he's talking
about they were going to spend how much
money two trillion dollars with two
people in there the speaker and one
other person
so they they said it was too dangerous
for them to come and vote meanwhile
they're going to the grocery store and
expecting a grocer to be there and
somebody to bag their groceries they
expect the truck drivers to be driving
they expect the ups guy to show up the
nurses to be there unvaccinated
healthcare workers right nobody was
vaccinated at the time by the way
so anyways i i stood up i objected i
said i'm here today to make sure that
our our republic doesn't die in an empty
chamber by unanimous consent is it like
a cryptographic uh vulnerability to vote
by just vote digitally and then confirm
it with a video chat
well okay they they hadn't by the way i
think they need a constitutional
amendment to do that
um
what they have come up with since then
is a vote by proxy where a human being
tells another human being on the floor
vote for me this way so that they can't
be compromised it's basically human so
it works like this i say to
my friend thomas massey i'm going to
just stay in georgia this week while
congress is in session thomas will you
vote for me and then thomas goes sure
i'll be your proxy and so i can i've
never done this by the way and i will
not do it and i haven't either yeah we
don't participate but
this is what members of congress do some
of them have just hardly ever shown up
literally hardly ever shown up and
someone else just votes for them so this
is like a representative having a
representative that sounds like they're
not doing their job
they're not doing their job unless you
count their job as going to fundraisers
i mean they would literally attend
fundraisers that's right instead of
coming to vote terms
do you think term limits will end these
these fun nonstop fundraisers i don't
think so
i i don't think i mean i've sponsored
term limits i'm for term limits let's
try it
but i'm for it the problem is not that
the people who've been there a long time
sell out it's the problem is that people
get there and sell out on day one
and then you have people who announce
their retirements and you would think
well now they're unchained they they've
no obligations and they'll vote their
conscience
no they once they know that they're no
longer going to be there the voting
record doesn't improve if anything their
attendance goes down and yeah
or something the ones that are retiring
i'll give you an example adam kinzinger
that's well we don't know what he is
what is he
he's nancy pelosi's little little baby
boy
so anyways adam kinzinger he he voted
yes with the democrats competes act last
week he was the only republican to vote
yes for it so he's not running for
congress again so he is completely sold
out and voting whichever way the
democrats are happy with but um back to
thomas's story
which how much of this do you want me to
tell it's up to you oh my gosh i had
president trump yelling at me oh my
he called me up that day for the for the
having the audacity to say that members
of congress should show up and vote
yelling at you for what
uh
i don't know he was afraid it might slow
down the process of getting two trillion
dollars out the door and twelve hundred
dollar checks in the mailbox well let's
reference whether you remember this it
was in march of 2020 it was the shutdown
no one knew what covid was going to do
everyone was freaking out people they
didn't know what the outcome was going
to be so president trump was pushing
through
thomas massey was trying to say no we
have to do this correctly we still have
a constitution that has not gone away
and i'm proud of him i totally support
him for what he did so he said he said
he would on the phone he told me he was
going to come at me like i'd never seen
never never in your life before have you
seen the way in which i will come at you
charles that's awesome yeah
i feel like he also reminded me which is
true he's more popular than me in
kentucky
and he said it would be the end of me
and i i tried to tell him this was
constitutional and we needed to do it
this way and it would still pass anyway
because most people were for it we just
couldn't break the constitution today
and he repeated you know i'm coming at
you like you've never seen
never in your life before have you seen
the way in which i will come at you and
then he he said that i was a
he i didn't know what that meant but
before i got back to my seat i i found
out
he said i was a third-rate grandstander
on twitter
on twitter yeah and you're in trouble
when that happens yeah and that i should
be thrown out of the gop and
and some other stuff so when i walked
out of the floor having objected and
making everybody show up to work which
they hated by the way they still
wouldn't take a recorded vote even
though they had a quorum they would not
put their names on that bill and when i
walked out the the press wanted to know
what i had to say for myself that my own
president had called me a third-rate
grandstander and i looked at him i said
i was offended i'm at least second rate
did you guys see that story
it was it was several months ago
actually but video recently got released
of planes coming into new york carrying
illegal immigrants undocumented
so uh they were being uh shuffled into i
think tennessee and the uh the biden
administration was using military
flights air force to bring you know
undocumented kids illegal immigrants
across the country we got video released
of one of these moments so there's a big
story about these planes landing in
westchester new york
video a body camera footage is released
so these co these federal contractors
refusing to show id refusing to explain
what they're doing the police who are
doing security at the airport are like
what are what is this this flight is
past curfew you're not supposed to be
landing who are these people where are
their ids and then one of the federal
contractors said something to the effect
of if the american you know you know
help us if the american people find out
what's what's going on what we're doing
and the cop says why and he goes because
the government has betrayed the people
and that's a line from this leaked
footage of the new york post had this i
see stories like that
and it makes and everything you're
telling me right now
and it really feels to me you know one
of the reasons the media dislikes you
guys so much especially you marjorie is
because
you are regular people and you've
somehow got into the room and they're
they're they're you know they're holding
their wine glasses pinkies i'm like oh
heavens you know like the help is in
here like what do we do like the the
please pretty sure they said that you
guys both you guys both were like
basically independently wealthy or and
had enough that you didn't need to make
money out of congress when you got there
i would imagine i know you said you had
a construction company yes we have a
construction company
but for me it was more about i've i've
got so disappointed in republicans not
doing what they said they were going to
do and i just got so concerned and i
thought you know what i'm going to run
for congress and and hold them
accountable and actually i want to be
part of a republican conference that
does the things that say that we say
we're about and also i mean i i'm i
never apologize for this and i and i
always say it i'm very proud i've always
supported president trump and i loved
his policies and so when i was running
for congress he was running for
reelection for a second term and that
was something i wanted to be a part of i
really wanted to be a part of a
republican member of congress
hopefully finishing out his america
first agenda
now i don't like the spending i'm also
honest about that i want to see or we
should have a balanced budget actually
i'd like to see a budget that makes a
profit i'd like to pay off the debt
these are things that i think we should
be working towards but um he was the
first uh you know president that i was
that i believed in because i felt like
every other politician and and most of
the time they've been selling out our
country they've moved for decades
they've moved us into this global
economy which is hurting every single
american that's outside of politics
that's selling our country out and so
you know not not it wasn't about money
or a career choice at all for me it was
about i feel like i have to do this you
know for my kid's future and and i
didn't trust anyone else to do it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 00 pm
now don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you